and they're going to be thinking very
differently so I think that by chance
wow what an amazing luck piece of luck I
had that mewing is something to do with
faces kids are interested in doing it
and it's it's out there now and you
can't stop that
look
there's a chance we can bring the ship
around
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I am Dr Brett Weinstein and I
have the great honor and pleasure of
sitting with my friend Mike mu this
morning Mike Mew is an orthodontist from
Britain and I know what you're all
thinking but as I understand it he is
not responsible for the terrible teeth
of the British people in fact he's been
working very hard to fix the problem at
the root cause Mike Welcome To Dark
Horse thank you very much Brad pleasure
to come on
so you have been a guest on Dark Horse
before I got a lot of very positive
commentary on that episode
and uh we are doing a second episode
because you as I understand it are uh
engaged in an active struggle as of this
week for your license to to practice is
that accurate very yeah I was in court
well by saying course I will Define that
as it's a general Dental Council
tribunal so clearly you need to regulate
dentists that is important
and this is the court within the dentist
Council
and this court is empowered if they want
to take your license from you totally
yeah yeah that's you know they can't put
me in prison you know they can't they
can't even find me any money that they
don't have that power but they have the
power to place sanctions upon me such as
not to do Orthodontics or my version
orthotropics
to stop me practicing either for a
temporary suspension or complete Erasure
so they stop my bus they stop me from
practicing it's so it's my career on the
line that's how I earn my money that's
what I've invested
my savings into
and this is not for you even just your
career uh as I understand
um from you and from reading about you
your version of Orthodontics is an
extension of work done by your father
John mu do I have that right
I think there's two sides to this first
of all side is
the the trying to understand the
also you know crooked teeth malotion
yeah trying to understand the problem
that we're treating and then trying to
develop a treatment system to correct
the problem
so
my father observed that all was not well
within orthodontic therapy and he
made many cognitive leaps of reason he
did a lot of research a lot of
Investigation he wasn't the only one I
mean by any any methods I think that he
came up with better clarity about the
whole system and
we've attempted to treat patients on the
system following first principles and
that's that's a hard thing to do
and I've got a clinic where I try to so
our our thinking is rather than trying
to make the teeth fit the mouth
or the face we're trying to make the
face fit the teeth
so we're trying to change the way facial
form
with the way your face grows so you have
better craniofacial structure
Goods good architecture
good function and naturally straight
teeth and it follows
we're trying to follow the science and
the biggest
dichotomy I've got is you know the
biggest big bit between me and
conventional Orthodontics is the cause
why are teeth crooked yeah that's my
biggest
yeah I I must say that there's something
about the way you've described this that
doesn't sit right with me because it's
like really like a competition between
two schools of thought one in which you
move the teeth and one in which you
reshape the jaw
you know you get to it at the last
statement you made it is a question of
why the teeth don't fit in the first
place and addressing that issue at best
so that the jaw never forms badly and
the teeth naturally find the right place
is the obvious uh best remedy right yeah
yeah I I
particularly having struggled for 10
years to correct people the the message
that comes through more and more and
more the the more I the more experience
I gain is we've got this is something
that we need to be correcting
um Iron I ran a petition
um a few years ago that was still
running a campaign called prevent
crooked teeth but I'd love if you could
put that as link number one if I write
down links to to set prevent crooked
teeth
um
because
the answer has to be prevention and then
that's that's the the beauty of trying
that that's what science is trying to do
when you try to understand a problem is
think about
basically if you can prevent it
well so let me um maybe to orient the
audience a little bit let me yes tell
people how I encountered you and what my
reaction was because I think it's
actually the Quick Way in here
now I had my teeth moved as a young
person as an older person I lost five
teeth to what was apparently harm done
by the orthodontist who moved my teeth
too quickly caused short roots that then
caused the teeth to become unstable
effectively my teeth aged faster than
they should have because we were honest
borrowed from a capacity of teeth to
adjust their own position in order to
move them across my jaws
so perfectly placed this question as an
evolutionary biologist this is one of a
number of questions that uh
demand an answer right so as a you know
if I see fat people
I think as an evolutionary biologist
that's not how selection built them what
is the cause and I can see that there is
a cause in the fact that all of our
ancestors were stressed for resources
for a very obvious reason that they
um if their population had too much food
resource then the population rapidly
grew until it didn't have too much and
so virtually every ancestor we had was
resource stressed virtually all of the
time and so I know that at least part of
the problem with obesity
is that we have a situation in which we
have food in abundance that situation is
stable and so we don't have the
self-limiting capacity that selection
would otherwise have built into us so
that's a case that most people will know
the answer or at least understand it
when it's described but then there are
lots of other cases where something has
gone wrong in human beings that demand
an answer why do so many human beings
need eyeglasses why do so many young
people have acne right why why are these
defects apparent in us in a way that we
don't typically see defects in wild
animals
so in any case having been through
intense orthodontia as a young person
and then suffered the consequences later
this was a question on my mind why are
our teeth so crooked and I had various
hypotheses floating around in my mind as
to what might be causing it whether or
not
um you know getting your genes for your
jaw shape from a different place than
you got your jeans for your teeth could
potentially do it of course that doesn't
make a lot of sense when you think about
the fact that you know dogs apparently
have a developmental program that
results in you know you can breed a
Chihuahua on a Great Dane and it doesn't
have a problem with you know the teeth
fitting in its jaws so that's not a
great explanation I wondered if it was
something about
the way we were sleeping and the
pressure of pillows and other novel
phenomena pushing on the face or
something like this but then I heard you
speak on this issue and you know anytime
I hear somebody from a discipline that's
not evolutionary talk about evolutionary
Dynamics there's a part of me that you
know has to uh I I have to be seated
because the leaps in logic tend to be so
large that
um you know it just leaves me ranting at
the screen but I heard you speak and
frankly I didn't hear you make a serious
error in fact the case you made was
spectacularly coherent Drew on exactly
the kinds of evidence that I would hope
the case would be based on and it made a
great deal of sense and so
I knew from hearing that I was hearing
somebody who had the expertise that I
lack completely which is what's going on
with teeth how do they work
who was also able to step out of their
discipline into my discipline and not
sound like a fool and so okay well done
B the discovery that this case that you
have made and the program of uh
orthotropics is that the term you use
for it yeah that's that's the term we
try and use for the correction of this
problem you know the the orthodontics
correct crooked teeth orthotropics is
what we're
come up with so that uh program
um is obviously a threat to an entire
industry do you know what a laundry suit
is
the clothing you wear when you are
finally forced to do your laundry
do you know what the opposite of a
laundry suit is it's the stuff you reach
for first when your clothes come out of
the dryer it's your favorite shirt for
example
when MSN and Main contacted us about
sponsoring a show I'd never heard of
them turns out they specialize in the
design and manufacture of favorite
shirts when I got my first package from
isn't in Maine it was instant love the
quality is obvious at first touch
mizen and Maine are the inventors of the
performance fabric dress shirt and they
really are comfortable
these shirts combine the flexibility of
your favorite athletic wear with the fit
in style of a custom dress shirt
lightweight breathable and moisture
wicking they're actually the best dress
shirts I've worn and they are machine
washable that means no more expensive
trips to the dry cleaner
Plus for cold weather they've got
amazing flannels pants sweaters and
jackets made from the same Mison and
Main material they've become famous for
they've got over 30 000 five-star
reviews so you know their stuff is high
quality
if you wear dress shirts and haven't
tried missing in Maine you're missing
out it really has become my favorite
shirt so if you want the best cold
weather clothing find your next favorite
shirt at mizzen and Main shop their
Black Friday sale and get 25 off
site-wide with code thankful25 that's 25
off the entire site when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d m a i n.com and use
the promo code thankful25 our second
sponsor for this episode is eight sleep
sleep is necessary and good sleep
changes your whole outlook without good
sleep we are condemned to be less
healthy and less productive and let's
face it when you're not sleeping well
you're probably also less attentive to
the needs of the people you love
despite the importance of good sleep
more than 30 percent of Americans
struggle to get it and temperature is a
prime culprit
it's well known that people who share a
bed often have different preferred sleep
temperatures age sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that ate sleep makes easy to
obtain or a warm room with a cool bit
you schedule your temperature
preferences for your side of the bed in
advance and if you want to adjust it
during the night that's easy too just a
couple of Taps on your phone and eight
sleep changes the temperature in the
desired Direction
the Pod Pro cover by eight sleep is the
most advanced Solution on the market for
thermoregulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110.
the temperature of the cover adjusts
each side of the bed based on the Sleep
stage Biometrics and bedroom temperature
dynamically creating the optimal sleep
environment for you
eight sleep users fall asleep 32 faster
reduce sleep interruptions by 40 and get
more restful sleep overall
and with 30 percent more deep
restorative sleep on average they are
likely to benefit from faster physical
recovery improved hormone regulation and
increased mental clarity
finally the wake up feature which can
signal you with temperature change and
or slight chest level vibrations isn't
jarring at all it's much gentler than
any standard alarm
Heather and I were both skeptical about
the value of a technologically enhanced
mattress but were now totally convinced
we are surprised how much we appreciate
this bed when we're home and how much we
miss it when we're away
go to eightsleep.com Dart course to
check out the Pod Pro cover and save 150
bucks at checkout eight sleep ships to
the USA Canada and the UK our third
sponsor for this episode is Vivo
barefoot shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet not vivos vivos are feet first
foot forward shoes that will change your
approach to walking evos are made by
people people with feet who know how to
use them here at Darkhorse we love these
shoes they are Beyond comfortable the
tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they're really
fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution
humans evolve to walk move and run
Barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a Health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might because their shoes make their
feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases 60 percent in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
Vivo has a great range of Footwear for
kids and adults for every activity from
hiking to training as well as everyday
wear yes they are a certified B Corp
pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it
go to Vivo barefoot.com Darkhorse to get
an exclusive 20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash Darkhorse
right to the extent that there is a
better mechanism for addressing
malocclusion that's a threat but even
worse because your argument is so
powerful and so well grounded with
respect to what the ultimate cause is in
effect if people were to take seriously
your proposal and they were to chase
down the details and the effect of
remedying the root cause which is that
we are now eating things as uh you know
developing infants and children that do
not cause the right feedbacks to shape
our faces correctly that that is the
root cause it's not that our teeth don't
know where to go it's that by the time
our teeth are trying to figure out where
to go our Jaws don't have enough room in
many cases they aren't shaped correctly
for the teeth to meat so were we to take
that seriously
Orthodontics would become a very rarely
needed specialty only in cases where
there was something like a congenital
abnormality that was not responsive to
proper diet which is usually below a
percent
yeah
so
it is not surprising to me having
confronted power a number of times in my
career
to discover that you are now on the
wrong end of a board
uh adjudicating the question of whether
or not you are qualified to practice
your profession
right in essence people who threaten an
industry often find themselves faced
with some exercise of power
that will shut them up
um and I you know I must say it's not
it's not surprising in light of what I
believe you have discovered but it is
extremely disturbing
yes it's disturbing me at the moment
well you yes you are facing uh is it a
tribunal is that a fair term yeah
yeah
um so
let's
you know I've now uh ranted quite a bit
here about power and evolution and
Medicine
yeah I mean it it
for me life's really tough at the moment
you know because
it's
if you were coming up with new ideas
you're ahead of the game
they're almost by definition there isn't
the objective evidence to validate what
you're saying
one thing they don't want
in these types of pro tribunals are
ideas logical trains of thoughts
I don't know why but it seems that in
medical tribunals this is almost a
disavowed
um argument they always want
um
objective evidence and I think there's I
almost think that's a symptom of The
Wider problem that we've got in medicine
that you know it's almost as if the
the power the the structure within
medicine is almost you know it looks to
the top to come down with ideas and if
you come in with you know the the the
bright guy the Maverick guy coming in
from the edge of medicine this is the
classic example you know the Maverick
that comes in with some great idea and
Medicine tries to stop him this is being
repeated within medicine Time and Time
Memorial
and it's almost interesting the way that
in this tribunal they're not going to
allow me just to give you know a
coherent argument I I could say from a
scientific basis that unless you can
invalidate
unless you can falsify my argument then
I it'so facto QED here I stand please go
away
yes um and this is extremely troubling
uh you know there are a number of angles
we could come at this from one is that
there is a
problem in any discipline in which there
is both a clinical aspect you know
there's clinical Dentistry where we
treat problems that people have with
their teeth but there is also a
theoretical question
surrounding teeth and jaws and you know
you have used this theoretical Realm
in order to come up with a very
practical and I believe from what I've
seen very effective program we're not
only it is effective but changing People
is many man hours
many hours is unprofitability
so however effective the methods I have
they're not profitable
they're not profitable I mean to me that
sounds like it's Downstream quite a ways
because I mean clearly you know Brett
I've got and I would say at least a
third of my patients the facial changes
I gain are just unbelievable you know
it's crazy did you really change that
personal and to meet the person it's
crazy you know I often say if I could
take 10 of the increased earnings that
these kids get
um that's all I would ever need you know
a third of my patients were we match up
quite well to what you've got with
Orthodontics I think possibly better and
a third of them you know we make some
improvements but you know that we we
don't get a significant Headway you know
and it's been a huge effort actually I
think those are old statistics I think
I've improved that's my last decade
trying to improve that but what it's
taught me it's just still not profitable
just as not profitable to do this well
you know yes not profitable but they're
steps removed from the real problem okay
not profitable even if it was profitable
you're talking about
an industry of professionals that
effectively need to retrain completely
in terms of their approach right so
that's implausible on its face but even
worse than that
from the perspective of the industry
itself there would be very little need
for this uh specialty if people's faces
were shaped correctly in the first place
um Downstream no doubt but I think that
we forget because you know to take it
beyond the reason I um published this
the concept craniofacial dystrophy so I
I need you know everyone was talking
about the people like crooked teeth
we've got this you know rapid rise in
crooked teeth and we've got this rapid
rise in sleep apnea we've got a rapid
rise in forward head posture George
problems
um most autolaryngology you know ENT
problem so something generally is going
wrong with this structure and it seem to
be relationships you know there's all of
these rapid curves going up and what's
going on and
but as far I I'm people come to me
because they want straight teeth that's
what they want now when I talk about
faces and your alignment you know that
they blind to that and I guess now it's
why a lot of people come to see me but I
think the value I add outside the
crooked teeth is enormous and I think
we're we're only just scratching the
surface of that but I still you know
when people coming to see me are still
look at how much would it cost to have
my teeth straightened this way how much
does it cost to see Dr Mew and they're
willing to take
um two or three maybe even four times
the cost you know because they now know
some of the value of what they're
getting back
however it's costing me 10 times the
cost
put that on but I still think that is a
fraction of the cost if they do well of
the value they get out of it in their
lifetime because you know what more do
you want in a life
right and you know one of the things
that I've learned in in following you is
that we're really you know teeth are the
place that this shows right it's the
obvious sign but the number of Health
consequences we are potentially talking
about things that people care about like
sleep apnea for example yeah it has
everything to do with the shape of your
skull and so the fact that we have put
an you know we have disrupted a normal
feedback
that that is causing health issues the
one that we have a it's not even a
remedy it's a cluge moving the teeth
around after the Jaws formed incorrectly
is not a proper remedy it's a you know
it's a it's a cosmetic fix and yes it
has some benefits right that you know
the teeth meeting removes some of the
pathologies but it certainly doesn't
address the majority of them
and
if I can just add one more thing here
which I think we need to straighten out
in order for the audience to understand
what we're really talking about there is
a fundamental disagreement between
you and your father and Weston Price I
guess uh on the one hand
and your uh field and its authorities on
the other and that is about whether or
not the
epidemic of malocclusion that is the
failure of the the teeth to meet
correctly
is the result of bad genes that have
spread through the population and are
now causing a pathology that must be
addressed in the now traditional way
or whether there is some other what I
would argue is a developmental cause
that has nothing to do with genes right
now
why you're on the defensive here is
mysterious to me I mean it's not really
because I know how power works and I
know how Industries work and I know that
people
do not surrender their uh their role in
the world they come up with reasons to
preserve it but the fact is this isn't
even a difficult question
when did malocclusion start to spread as
an epidemic
well I mean you know we can look in the
fossil records and you go back
um go back 12 000 years ago plus there's
we don't have a lot of skulls yeah we've
got all those goals but the evidence is
10 to 12 000 years ago virtually nothing
sure and then it progressively increases
what you do have is a it change as soon
as we saw you know as soon as we started
picking up a flint tool and cutting meat
then we didn't have to do as much of
this
because before you you know you incise
food with your entices you cut food with
your own sizes so as soon as you had a
stone tool you were doing less all right
and that was probably the first change
in our own sizes you had to
um wear them so much that you developed
a gap between them from where and that
gap having teeth overlapping was the
first clue a first change but then we
had a long period with more or less
straight teeth with the majority of
people having straight I'm going to say
to the end of the medieval period
mostly everyone's got all 32 teeth in
their mouth
okay so that's up to about 1400 in this
is in Britain now we've got to take some
some locality so you know the developing
Europe most people have got all their
teeth in working in function including
the wisdom teeth up till about the 1400s
then
it clearly becomes more prolific
particularly in cities and in the
wealthier groups whereas if you go out
into the farms and onto the fields
there's less crookedness less disruption
and the way faces grow and the
crookedness of the teeth and then of
course you hit the Industrial Revolution
and it just starts to spiral up I think
it really got prolific at the turn of
the 1900s and this is when Orthodontics
started because Orthodontics you know we
had a method um there were several
methods but the one we seemed to have
followed was a guy called Edward angle
in the U.S who made
mechanical systems that could make the
teeth straight they had people that were
willing to pay for it you had a method
that could do it and then basically an
industry started and that's it worked
made heat straight so we see a
spectacular rise starting uh at the
beginning of the 20th century is that
right okay so let's take your Fields
perspective at face value
okay
let's say that in order for your fields
to be correct about the cause here some
new bad genes have to have emerged at
that moment and spread right now if I do
a back of the envelope com uh
calculation all right if I say okay
let's say that a new Gene for
malocclusion
shows up in 1900 because people are
modern and they're not going to Star
starve almost no matter what it doesn't
have the negative selective pressure
that it would ordinarily have
now let me give that Gene the benefit of
every doubt right let's make it a
dominant gene so that everybody who has
a single copy has uh malocclusion with
this new form right
and so it shows up in one person
and then let's say that I set the
parameters for maximum rate of speed
that makes I mean just even beyond
anything that makes sense let's say it's
a dominant gene
that the person who had it first the
person in which the mutation occurred
uh has six children
well half of them will get it all right
three of those children will have this
new kind of malocclusion and then let's
have each of those three children have
six children of their own three of whom
will get it right so this is like a
ridiculous rate of spread this is you
know this is winning the lottery as far
as some new Gene is concerned spreading
across the population
well
at that rate
in a hundred years the total number of
people that would have had that new kind
of malocclusion if I'm doing the
calculation correctly is under 125.
it hasn't spread like wildfire across
yeah it's not effective we've just hit
apparently to this this week we're
hitting eight billion people on the
planet
yeah
and there's a lot of people compared to
what you said 125 right so the point is
I don't even know what argument is being
made if you really if we all agree that
malocclusion has spread like wildfire
since 1900.
then bad genes ain't even on the list
I'm not saying nobody has malocclusion
because they have a bad Gene I'm sure
that happens yep but the idea that this
thing the point is it spread like a
contagion right the list of things that
can do that is small one thing that can
do it is a pathogen for which there's no
indication here as I understand it
another thing they can do it is a
cultural change that spreads
horizontally across a a population like
a change in the diet of children
and so you know to me this is open and
shut you at least have a viable
hypothesis for what's going on in
addition to clinical evidence of uh
positive effect on your patients right
your feel has a nonsense story that
should take any evolutionists you know a
few minutes with a single envelope to
falsify so why are you on the defensive
at all that's the question I mean if it
isn't power that's the obvious answer is
that it's power defending itself
it's this crazy situation where you know
I sit down the liars and I say well look
well I didn't mention that between
2009 and 2015 I wrote to every every
government body every everything just
saying look we need to debate on utility
marocution because I wanted to work
within the parameters of my field
I guess naively but I I tried that and
you know so I've demonstrated that you
know this goal of trying to have you
know the scientific process well this is
you know how can a profession be
treating you know at least 30 if not 50
60
you know I I had one girl I treated who
said every other child in her class had
fixed braces clearly I was treating her
so that's a hundred percent of the class
now
is openly admitted within the profession
that we don't know the causals they
don't know the cause of the problem it's
an open it's it's key discuss
a bit bit briefly
so we don't know the cause we're
treating a huge number of the population
and often at the public expense like in
the UK and they refuse to engage in
debate with me of any description of any
form on any level
and then
wine full of forward wine to today or
yesterday I go into court where they're
saying
it's genetic and that's the main stamp
on this case is it's genetic and I'm
saying to my legal team well surely all
we have to do is prove that it's
environmental say thank you very much
let's we go home now
and they're saying it's not like that
you know we've got to we've got to argue
all the other points you know every
single little bit that you know clearly
there's reams of allegations that's what
they always do
and I sometimes I despair you know
science I
yeah
yeah well you know
I I increasingly find myself in this
spot where having seen enough of these
cases I can't really be surprised but
then you know the part of me that's just
a regular human being is shocked right
like you know you've actually made
progress on this puzzle not only
theoretical progress which would be
great enough on its own but clinical
progress right you should be commended
for that even if your colleagues want to
keep doing what they're doing the fact
is you are at least a new school of
thought that has tremendous promise for
ultimately uh addressing this this
problem and you know it's a classic case
of no good deed goes unpunished yeah
some I I think somehow try make being
able to improve people's facial
appearance and General Health there must
be some money in there somewhere you
know I'm sure somehow you know I'm good
on this what's really surprised me
though Brett was that me putting some of
this information online
went crazy amongst the you know what we
call adolescence the youth the you know
I guess now the younger 30s
you know I I made a presentation
I gave one of those presentations you
know had I done my research I probably
wouldn't have done but I made the
presentation
and at the end of the presentation I was
just swamped with these young guys
mainly and some girls just wanted to
know how they could improve their facial
form and clearly
it's not
what I had in mind it wasn't thinking
like this and I kind of thought to them
you know you'd be crazy to try because
it's change is difficult you know
changing how you you're changing your
posture is changing you
is a difficult thing to do
anyway I already had some exercises up
for my patients and then
um we had some alerts out on my name you
know people didn't Google my name that
often back then so or say put my name on
places
we kept track and I I sort of again
questions I was answering questions on
strange forums and then all of a sudden
it did this mewing thing
kicks off
and it's you know it I checked the other
day because it's you know you do you
know you you want to check how these
things are doing and on Tick Tock the
the hashtag mewing had been seen
1.7 billion times
1.7 billion times
I mean
so
people
who are really interested in what I'm
saying are people with faces
have a
eighth is going to interest you
yeah and you know it's it is we then go
on to things because well I think one of
the things held it back is this emotive
issue of being good looking or not
of course because I make good looking
people and I take kids that aren't good
looking and I make them good looking and
even just I remember mentioning to
someone that's what I did and they were
utterly horrified
and they were saying oh you know we've
got enough girls with anorexia without
you jumping in and saying your face
could be beautiful
and I mean
well they've got a point no no they
don't no they don't and this is
let's just
sketch this out here okay
you make people so I one of the things
that you said in in uh one of the First
videos I saw of you discussing this
question was that now that you
understand this process you look at
people and you see like people who who
have been in a car accident that our
faces are distorted by this
developmental failure and that you now
can't help but see it right
which
means that in effect whatever it is and
you know I fully believe that the
at the root is an innocent error people
did not know that in changing the diet
they were going to uh make people yeah
yeah yeah yeah the world is littered
within us on errors right it's littered
within the scenarios and it is not all
that unusual frankly to make an innocent
error that has you know uh millions or
billions of victims right that we do
this all the time with toxins yeah lead
impactful sounded like a great idea
sounded like oh man it just really deals
with that knocking problem
um but nonetheless okay so you've got an
innocent error
that is maiming people
a people who have been maimed in general
do not want to look this problem in the
eye right because the point is wait a
minute you know I could have been
handsomer I lived my entire life
Downstream of this error and you know
it's too late so people don't want to
face stuff like that that's one thing
but the point is at some level we adults
have to face that and we have to face it
even if there's nothing to be done for
us because there are an indefinitely
large number of generations to come who
have yet to be maimed in this way right
yeah that's the point is look
um are you the kind of person who would
maim children no I am not well then you
have a responsibility to look at this
question because if my commute is right
we are going to maim people who haven't
had it happen yet and then the same way
that we need to protect people from
child molesters and you know dangerous
painting hacks we have to protect them
from being maimed by this initially
innocent that is no longer innocent
because we're capable of seeing it yeah
we were so focused on education
so focused on that and yet so unfocused
on the development of our structure
right I unfocused and you know we become
increasingly
um
unfortunately we've become increasingly
divorced from the physical world right
people the younger you are the more your
life has been internet focused the more
easily you fall into this sort of sense
that life is an abstraction or it takes
place on screens and your body is an
inconvenience but the point is of course
no the the body is fundamental and to
the extent that you're neglecting it or
that you've been maimed by a mistake
like you were fed foods that were too
soft and didn't give the right feedbacks
to your jaw in a developmental process
um that's tragic but the real tragedy is
all of the people that this hasn't
happened to yet who it's gonna happen to
if we don't if we don't look at it
prevention
it's the obvious thing to do even even
for those of us for whom it's too late
this is just such a clear moral
obligation for us to uh to protect those
who have yet to to suffer from it that
um you know it's not surprising that
you're hearing an incoherent argument
from people who don't want to put that
together they don't yeah I never got an
argument you know but I've never had a
decent argument with any orthodontist
ever I mean they just we still you know
the classic thing is I'm at a conference
someone that points to me and goes I
can't believe you wanders over has a
graph Road me and I go terribly sorry I
say well have we ever thought about so
and so or so and so and they look at me
and go you're impossible to talk to and
walk off
and I'm thinking
yeah
no I mean uh you know and look
the fact is human progress
is Downstream of disagreeable people and
um
you know what Mike you're disagreeable
right that does not mean the way it
sounds but no no I know I get you I'm
getting no one right
back to what you said
one bucket per second because we're
talking about I can recognize these car
crashes and accidents yeah so clearly I
work obtainingly hard I rarely get the
time off to go and pick the kids up last
Monday I just took the afternoon off
because it's my paperwork download
crimes decided I'll take the great
pleasure of picking the kids up
that moved class since I last picked
them up that's how long ago you know
since I picked them up and it was this
Christmas coming up
and so I I found out where they were
being picked up I picked them up and I'm
standing there outside the classroom and
I can spot so they're in primary school
and I'm looking at five six seven
eight-year-olds
and I can spot which ones aren't growing
well
and I know that literally not that much
hard work and effort right now
well designed well implemented over a
significant period of time could
massively help prevent these problems
you know really cheap things chewing gum
you know where we're lack masticatory
effort just from when your child will
get home in the evening to when they go
to bed to gum you know it's not complex
um you know I've got a video called The
Five Point prevention strategy it's
really simple video to prevention but
it's it's blowing my mind I can spot
these kids I can see them in front of me
and
well you know look there's a reason
um that Cassandra in what she is right I
feel Cassandra I fail for Cassandra yeah
of course you do you the point is that
was a warning it was a warning to people
like you and frankly me I I don't
remember if we talked about this in in
our last discussion but you know I the
thing that woke me up more than anything
else was when I discovered a flaw in the
system that we use uh to test drugs and
I discovered that the mice had been
broken in a very particular way that
made those mice prone to tell us that
drugs were safe when they really weren't
what I thought was going to happen next
was I was going to publish my paper
which turned out to be a struggle
and the scientific Community was going
to say oh [ __ ] what have we done there
was going to be you know yes some you
know ass covering and all of that but we
were going to
do everything in our power to solve the
problem so that going forward we would
not continue to compound it you know
what happened I don't know this is going
at the moment to carry on what happened
is nothing
I tried for 10 years to alert people to
this problem as far as I know nothing
was ever done what's more the panels
that were put together to discover what
the problem was systematically avoided
it
right so
that told me something we were willing
to leave our scientific mechanism broken
so that it would continue to Blind
scientists generation after generation
what's more this thing has now come
roaring back into my life because
as far as I know the very same mice that
were broken in the very same way that I
recognized back in you know 1998 and 99
right this is more than 20 years ago now
those same mice are now being used to
test the safety of covid vaccines for
authorization for use in children who
don't need them
so you know the point is that story told
me look okay your Cassandra and there
ain't just one it happens to everybody
who discovers something really important
that upends an entire field or
discipline or whatever you see and Brett
if this was
um in the Computing world
you know you come out with your Widget
the widget demonstrates work because
Computing either works or it doesn't
work it's a gadget you'd have made
billions of pounds and you'd have your
um mini Silicon Valley Empire that you
gently start branching out on and you
you'd affect the same attitude that you
affected and listen to other areas and
you'd probably be a you know your finger
in 20 companies by now
right if this were If This Were the kind
of discipline where you could just
simply say well I don't care that you
don't believe me my widget's going to be
30 faster than yours because I
understand something you don't you're
right this would just simply it would
spit out a profit and it would be much
easier you wouldn't have to defend
yourself on logical grounds against
people who are no no no because the
widget worked and you'd made money on it
right instead somehow you and I are
living in an era where you are seriously
actually having your your credential
jeopardized in a formal trial in the
same era where doctors are being
empowered encouraged and maybe even
required to uh disrupt the reproductive
capacity of children who decide that
they are born in the wrong body
like this system does not make sense
right did you understand
this is an era where we have yeah
disrupting normal functional organs
because of something that a child thinks
you know it it you know it's more
interesting than that Brad because you
see
um take take my K let me just think
about what I can say about this case and
what can't I say about this case Okay
because it's been in the newspaper they
divulged quite a lot of the information
about the case so now all of a sudden I
can I can take a little bit more freely
so
um one of the regulations against me is
that this child was normal she didn't
need treatment
well I mean this is the metric that
they're validating that on is the teeth
and the position of the teeth and how
the teeth were and of course the
position of her teeth were was the same
as everyone else in a modern society
okay in fact I I you know if I won't go
on
I won't no I'm going to more detail on
that
the
um now I'm saying that I can change the
way faces develop and I can make the
face look better
okay and I
how can I talk about the conversation
any fact that's okay I won't take any go
anymore that's what I'm saying that's
what they're they're challenging that I
can't change facial form
however in I can demonstrate that
there's a significant environmental
etiology into the way faces grow then at
least there's a possibility that I could
have done that okay now they're saying
it's a genetic etiology I'm saying it's
an environmentally geology clearly as we
discussed I feel if I win that argument
they don't have an argument anymore I'm
still saying it's completely in uh
environmentally there's a significant
environmental ideology
but if I can if it is a significant
environmental etiology and maybe there's
a chance that I can influence the way
the face grows then
then why can't I try to do that
you know people have
um breast implementation they have nose
jobs they have these other things you
know are they
Clinic clinically necessary
you know and
it's
you know we're on the edge of you're
telling people what and what they can't
do
without a full understanding of the
whole problem in the first place
um
so
you say that if you can win the argument
about this having an environmental cause
rather than a genetic cause that it's
all over and my concern is that that
almost suggests
a venue in which such a thing is
conceivable
and what the real question is not can
you win that argument because of course
you've already won that argument what
you were saying is at least logical and
what they are saying is completely
implausible it cannot be a genetic cause
because it has spread too fast for that
to make any sense
um the problem is it's not are you right
it's can you convince the people who are
wrong that they are wrong even given the
massive consequence that would have on
their own career prospects now
okay
well I think it really gets very
interesting because
after America
Britain is probably the next respected
scientific country in the world
now Britain has quite a
regimented system by how it appropriates
money or the distributes money so we
have things like the nice committee
nicely named Institute of
um
of clinical Excellence something like
that clinical and then I somewhere I
can't remember and
what they'll do is they they in theory
should look at the evidence relatively
freshly so if
I can gain Traction in the UK there are
systems in place because money is
because we we pay for the orthodontics
for so many people's Orthodontics that
you might actually get this changing and
you don't have a sort of central
organization
um Power structure in the UK you know
you don't have the drug companies
companies that make orthodontic
appliances tend to make other things as
well most clinics are conglomerates of
the clinics but they never get that big
I mean the only major player in all of
this would be things like Invisalign
and I could say in Happily to Invisalign
I've got some great ideas we could work
together
you know if there's a line give me a
shout
so this is this is unique and I think
you know I remember
um in the film
um
um Working Girl
where they finally come to uh the the
big round table and the guy who owns the
company or radio station he talks about
they couldn't get the the bus the Lorry
Down Under the tunnel and the little boy
said let the tight air out the tires
they're letting the air out the tires
and that was just enough for the Lorry
to go through the tunnel
and the idea whether the analogy is that
this guy by taking on a radio station
rather than a television channel takes
that he gets the same protection so he's
taking the air out of his tires a little
bit and
in a way
everyone's been looking
in medicine in these these big areas
these areas like drug companies these
areas like you know as you have fought
and they will fight back
because these are Big items he's a big
pharmaceutical companies who are
prepared they're organized this isn't
the first time you're not the first
person they've had to rain I hold back
they're practiced in Orthodontics we
don't have that
yeah you know my concern is that I think
and I don't know you you tell me if this
sounds plausible to you
but I think your mind is constructed in
an unusual way which is why you've
landed where you have
and so I think you're looking at these
folks and you are imagining that they
are more like you than they actually are
and the problem is that what they're
doing
does not involve probably does not
involve them Gathering and saying you
know
Mike Muse got a point and you know maybe
we can shut him down that's not what's
taking place what's happening is
they Intuit
um where their interests lie and they
reverse engineer arguments that advocate
for those interests and without question
so the the problem is they actually in
their own minds are heroes who are
shutting down a rogue orthodontist who
is in danger of hurting people he's not
doing what you should do he's
um you know he's out of control and you
know okay who are you talking to well
you're talking to an evolutionary
biologist who says whoa wait a minute
I've never heard anything reasonable
from orthodontists about where this
problem comes from but I did hear Mike
mu say a bunch of things that frankly
make perfect sense he couldn't be making
it up the story adds up completely right
the anthropological evidence the
evidence from wild creatures the
evidence from clinical practice all of
these things tell the same story this is
a developmental problem it's a
developmental problem with an
environmental cause that can be remedied
at the root and that could not possibly
be more frightening to people who make
their living correcting this very
problem they do not want it cured that's
the problem
and they know they don't want it cured
in their minds they probably believe it
can't be and that you are just simply
um you've lost the plot that's what they
think
so I think that's a very very fair
analogy of the situation
um
it's surprising how much time I spend
theorizing on these areas on why people
don't want to change
because you know I I've tried I think
you know his endless conversation where
you you I meet a dentist at a at an
event a social event
I have a chat with the dentist and they
follow my argument to a certain point
and then they'll always break at some
point and
it then becomes awkward because you know
what we can't go carrying they don't
want to talk about it or they they
disagree with me and then you can't go
back to talking about you know the
weather
um and then you you park company and you
you know that all you're going to do for
the rest of the night is not politely
you know high mate you know
and then you you afterwards you you go
through the conversation and you try and
work out what you said or what happened
and it I've got to the point now where
most dentists I won't even I just say
I've got some interesting different
ideas if it's a lay person if they don't
if they're not already
indoctrinated that's
a rude word to say
then they're fresh they're fertile
ground I mean this is why mewing has
spread so rapidly because these kids
they it make intuitive sense they they
weren't you know indoctrinated again in
that sort of
mold
so
with dentists I I just don't bother
anymore I mean it's just life's not long
enough I'm not going to try and convert
people one at a time they're welcome to
believe whatever they want to believe
well
I I have a question I'm hesitant to ask
you
um
I really don't like that it's a question
at all because I like what you're doing
is it possible
that actually
shoving you out of this broken
discipline is
ultimately a good thing from the point
of view of your perspective that you
will be Freer to reveal to the world the
harm that is being needlessly done and
the remedy for it outside yeah but
clearly I've had to sit down and
consider everything you know I what am I
going to do if I lose my license
what I can't do because you know but
I've lost money doing this you know this
Clinic here I've worked for the decade
you know from my early 40s to my I'm in
my early 50s now so that decade when
you're supposed to be earning the bread
you know big bread I mean you know your
40s and your 50s the two decades you you
you you you fill the family coffers up
with
I've sold my house
burnt the proceeds I'm Capital down
luckily my sister and her partner
um have been I've been a silent partner
in their development company so that's
the only reason I can carry on going
because I'm drawing money and capital
out of that
and now I'm on the point where I've I've
damaged my health massively and my
psychology to get to this point right
now my Crohn's is just flying I've only
got a limited diet I can do my weights
right down
so I I'm this juncture comes when I'm
maxed out on everything I've maxed out
of my finances I've maxed out on my
health
and
I'm not really making money anyway so if
I did lose my license what then you know
you've got to think of those realities
and my my right hand woman
who is brilliant she is brilliant and
she says to me she goes my
you could probably help the world
and make more money not actually
practicing on patients
yep
no I look uh
and honestly that I'm not stuck to
having you know I cannot move from an
area like a edge of London you know this
is the closest I can go because I need
to
um you need to be in a big demography to
attract the The Limited number of
patients who would want to come and see
me who can work that hard and pay that
money to get change you need to I
couldn't be on you know in on an island
somewhere it wouldn't work yeah but
I haven't had a more than a week or I've
had two two week holidays in the last
decade second one a honeymoon
um
I'm tired of the job I'm on call 24
hours a day my mobile is you know every
patient has my mobile I'm there for
everyone I mean you know
the stress the hassle the effort it goes
to to try and develop this is just
immense and yes to your question it may
be better for me not to work but
I I get the mortar Factor but then of
course I also get the factor that on the
surface value
many people will assume that I was wrong
now
it's first of all it's not the Martyr
Factor
it's that you are functioning inside a
set of constraints you're you're playing
a rigged game and yeah you're also
playing a rigged game where the biggest
obstacle you face is you're one guy and
so you can't work at scale right you
cannot personally work at scale
what you could do
is
um defeat your field I mean it's not
like they haven't had a chance to write
their own ship
you could defeat them from the outside
and
you know I I'm very hesitant to say this
because as somebody who has
um
taken up going around my field in order
to reveal what's wrong with it it is
possible for me to over interpret the
lessons of my own existence and I've
watched your existence Brad
right and so the question is look you
know you and I do different things but
they obviously overlap again your
description of the evolutionary context
of malocclusion was spot on so you know
you we have we've got analogous stuff
going on
uh in our in our minds
which tells me that maybe maybe the
answer is you need to scale up and that
I do think you need to fight tooth and
nail and you need to win this case but I
also have uh
doubts that you can because you're in a
venue that belongs to the people that
you're in there I'm in the Lion's Den
there's no question yeah and so I'm
being judged by people who think
that not having wisdom teeth is some
evolutionary development
yes and I must tell you this is
wonderful everyone including the guy who
sweeps the floor thinks that right I
have known since college that this story
didn't make any sense right the wisdom
peace story is a glaring error in
thinking right the idea that selection
hasn't fixed the fact that it produces
teeth You've Got No Room for come now
this election which can build an eye it
can make a dragonfly right it can you
know get uh a butterfly to migrate over
multiple Generations it can't solve the
problem that you've got too many teeth
for your jaw come now that that just
doesn't make any sense so obviously we
are looking for another kind of
explanation
and frankly you've come up with the only
one that makes any sense
right there are lots of things that
could cause this but they all run into
logical problems what you've come up
with is a coherent Global I'm sure it's
imprecise there are probably
imperfections in it but overarchingly
this story is so many orders of
magnitude better than the next nearest
competitor but there's no way anybody is
in a position to tell you don't do this
don't talk about it especially in an era
where we are you know literally
literally doctors are empowered to maim
children to wreck their reproductive
capacity based on uh what may be
temporary aspects of their
self-assessment so yeah who's telling
anybody what you can and can't do if
you're having a positive effect
right we're empowering people have
negative effects
but yeah but
then you know and we're in a world where
you're allowed to go and get breast
augmentation right yeah
that's that's not a necessary treatment
there's no way I mean look breast
augmentation I don't know very much
about it I'm sure it's destructive
removing breasts is inherently
destructive right we have medicine
removing people's functional breasts
right or you know or some having a nose
job for aesthetic reasons right you know
there are inherent risks from doing this
you know you do that they do often I
mean the Michael Jackson scenario where
you get issues from doing that and yet
no one thinks twice about doing it so
but I'm being accused of providing
unnecessary treatment right
no and all I'm saying to you is look I
am of course uh rooting for you in the
strongest possible terms because I do
see you as a Cassandra like figure I
think you if your message reaches the
people it needs to reach that you are
actually literally in a position to
prevent the maiming of hundreds of
millions of people at a minimum that is
an amazing amount of good so look I'm
rooting for you but but by the way
there was
um
a paper I wanted to bring up because I
thought I you know it would be
interesting just to give some people
some tag on
um the seriousness of this level here
this serious of this issue because
you know this we're talking about sleep
apnea and we're talking about people
whose faces don't grow well can get
sleep apnea and I you know maybe many
causes of sleep apnea but I deal with
the structural element you know the
structural cause of sleep apnea a lot of
people say that is a predominant cause
of sleep apnea
and you know it's they did a this is a
paper in Australia
um I'll I'll send you the paper
um by I can't even pronounce the guy's
surname the main author
anyway they um they looked at kids in
the three to twelve years old
who had
um sleep disordered breathing
so they defined these guys who were on a
waiting list for adenoidectomies
who snored that was the criteria of
where they classed them against normal
kids and these guys had a 12 point IQ
difference sorry 10 point IQ difference
and David gazelle has done other
research similarly showing where he
tooks people I think in La who had sleep
disorder breathing out of class offered
them all correcting it at tonsils and
adelites I believe taken out and then
watched how they improved in school and
these are these are really massive
changes I mean these aren't the
difference between whether you send your
kid to a state school or a private
school these are these are in the region
of whether you said send your kid to
school at all
I mean these are really big differences
and then I I I went to talk to a um
autolaryngologist an ENT surgeon
and I said to him that I thought that I
could argue that people with sleep apnea
um it was damaging their health and
seriously and ten percent of the adult
population in the developed world was
going to die a decade early from sleep
apnea and its consequences and he says
to me oh my it's more like 20 that's a
one in five and then I'm looking at
these two ends of the spectrum and I'm
thinking that
from a structural perspective if you've
got good architecture from a young age
what we're talking about is something in
the region of a 10 point difference in
IQ points
something like a 10 a decade more life
expectancy
and during that life you have that
longer healthier more intelligent life
you have a face that looks great and all
the benefits that brings you and I know
when I walk into rooms because I've got
a okay face better than average because
of the treatment I gained from my father
that I'm more socially acceptable yeah I
get more responses you know that's not
fair but that's the way it is no let's
flip this one on its head yeah
there is a reason that human beings are
so very sensitive to Beauty
okay
it has to do with the connection between
that beauty and function
so it is not surprising that people are
obsessed when they discover that you
have a secret maybe it's a partial
secret for people who have already
suffered the consequences of a
mal-shaped skull
but there's a reason that people are
very focused on being more beautiful
that reason is Downstream of the
underlying ultimate evolutionary
explanation for why we give a damn about
this that and the other right we are we
are selected to pay attention to this
characteristic because it matters and so
in some sense what you have just
described is the capacity of a human
being to use proxies of facial structure
to detect underlying health right
underlying health likely mental capacity
and so there's nothing about the story
you've just told that I think is
far-fetched in any way
the idea that your sleep and your
intelligence are are connected that your
sleep and your breathing are connected
all of these things make perfect sense
and so the amount of good that
potentially comes from your fixing our
understanding of this is incalculable
but
so too is the power that you're up
against because of the narrow short-term
interests of the people involved in
dictating whether or not you're you have
a strong case
yeah yeah yeah and here we go again you
know right the first time it won't be
last time by the way the the quote I say
and what you've just said is
I think
to a greater extent
your face is the CV of your health
beautiful
it's a you know you're displaying I'm
displaying to the outward world that not
only did I have the right genes I'm not
saying jeans aren't important I had the
right genes but also I was able to
elicit the right lifestyle the right
grit and determination grip your teeth
and carry on
to develop a good face
yep
and that's me so it was not only just
genetics but it's I've manipulated my
environment in such a way that I've
demonstrating here for you that I did
that and because of that I make a good
partner X Y and Z totally and the fact
is this is how sexual selection works we
select
characteristics that are good proxies
for underlying features that matter
right you know why why do uh why are
women so sensitive to uh whether a guy
is funny right funny is a proxy for a
kind of insight right it's kind of
insight that allows a person to get
farther in the world to discover
opportunities you know that exist can't
be seen by others and so none of these
things are idle it's not you know it's
aesthetic as a proxy for something
deeper yes what does good looking mean
right good looking means that all of the
things that you know yes the genes have
to be right in order to be good looking
it's not sufficient right if you take
good genes and you put them in a bad
developmental environment it doesn't
work out if you start it doesn't work
out
well but I remember going to a party and
someone goes Mike
you're looking healthy
and I go you mean I'm looking good
looking today
right totally same thing
different sides of the same coin
facial Health you know you know you know
when you meet someone and they look that
sort of dour sort of white shade you
know having a terrible time you see it
in their face
you know why wouldn't we you know why
would this is you know the great way the
way you convey
um how you are and that's important
within a group you know you need to know
with you we're not taking Bob hunting
today he doesn't look well he doesn't
look well right totally stay at home
we're we are hypersensitive to these
things for a reason and we have because
it is possible to be superficial about
this and also because it is possible to
treat you know to the extent
oh we'll do the makeup industry been
doing today right well exactly so you
can cheat and so we've lost the sense of
these things as a proxy because it's
become a kind of idle competition but
nonetheless these were good proxies and
you have tapped into
I don't know the motherload of good
proxies right because you know your
physical health is one thing but your
face is a concentrated location of focus
yeah it is your whole perception
apparatus is tied up in this it is the
indication and as you point out
um
the uh the face is the key to how far
you get in the world you how persuasive
you are it's shocking you know that
research on
um how far how much you more you earn
that prison sentence you know they did
this wonderful study right where they um
they took trial lawyer lawyers you know
judges who were making deciding the
sentence so you you've been found guilty
the judge has to decide the sentence so
they go all of these papers and the each
one had the photograph clipped to it
and then they just change the
photographs around same papers they
changed the photographs and they rated
these people you know what's this guy
like this you know you know how long
were you going to give this guy you know
and then you had this you know this you
know really you know
either ways the facial appearance and
how beautiful they were ranked made a
massive difference to the sentence these
judges gave them
right
um presumably without changing the facts
of the case uh and therefore the guilt
or innocence
um yeah absolutely I want to go back and
defend a term that I use because I
realize it covers two things both of
which are relevant here so yeah okay I
argued that people are being maimed and
I mean two things by that
um you tell me if I've got it right
one there is the maiming that comes from
a misunderstanding of malocclusion and
therefore a
um
extrinsic modification comparatively
late in life so in my case the moving of
my teeth through my jaws uh so the
treatment the treatment right the
treatment is an active uh an active case
but there's also and the one that I'm
really referring to
is the maiming that we do to our
children by not recognizing that the the
resistance of their food is what
dictates whether their jaws will form
correctly whether
don't forget posture as well you know
Brad because a lot of people getting
blocked noses they're hanging their
mouths open tongue isn't on the roof of
the mouth you know
behave all did some brilliant research
in um Caltech all he did was put an
uncomfortable piece of plastic
um
uh a bit of plastic shot but a plastic
on the roof of these monkeys you know
and the experimental ones but massive
facial changes the um controls beautiful
development as you would expect of most
little primates and so you know where
the tongue is is the secondary um Factor
we think and by the two of them are the
most important factors you know we go on
to breastfeeding and
um
um early nutrition uh as well those are
all in fact portal factors we think but
clearly we need Spotlight of modern
medical research to shine on these areas
but the diet we do think is the most
important right
um and you know we're not going to be
able to get into all of the things that
are potentially
uh connected but because every system
you know because the way you interact
with your food
um because of the interaction of
breathing the potential implications
this has for allergies and things are
are significant and then blocked noses
and allergies are going to have on
facial development because you can't
breathe out your nose you have to mouth
breathe right and that can become such a
habit and if you have this mix with
these soft muscles and where's your face
growing
right right
now when I look in schools and
[Music]
yeah I mean it's a you know it's a it's
a classically so we're going back to
what you're saying we've got the harm
from Orthodontics it does I mean I don't
want to cover that too much because
that's where I get the most resistance
from my colleagues and you know there
are many great colleagues out there who
are doing fantastic work but we all know
within the profession that some people
sometimes causing significant problems
and we talk about retractive
Orthodontics and We Know It Happens no I
think
um
you know power Wise It's a loser right
the idea of people doing active harm the
pushback you will get is of course
Monumental but the amount of good that
you will do
if you can modify the approach of
parents to their children early enough
in life that they prevent their children
from needing intervention that's really
where the lion should that's
that's the kind of Direction I want to
go in now because you know I've I've
again I've watched you I mean clearly
my ability to earn money with my chosen
subject is not as transportable
it's not as mobile particularly the
systems I use you I I you know if I
wanted to build my dream Clinic I would
have physiotherapists I would have
um uh behavioral psychologists
um you know a multitude of different
people you know because what I'm saying
you can you can effectively say I'm
telling people to stand up straight and
shut their mouths and build their
muscles up so using oral appliances yeah
that can help but then you know I'm
trying to change kids from this
for this you know standing up straight
so an oral plant is one element in this
broader change I need to do but it's
it's
you know you you can't just I can't just
say I can't go on a plane tomorrow fly
somewhere else and work in a van
well no that's not uh that's not where I
see you what what I am win or lose
frankly Mike win or lose
what I'd like to see is you to write a
book
um
how not to maim your children uh to
increase their earning potential and
their IQs without even trying right that
book where you alter the diet of the
child the child sleeps better ends up
smarter uh marries better because
they're handsomer and that tells a
potential mate that their higher quality
uh partner right that's a slam dunk and
you know you and I are both parents you
know how far out of your way you would
go to improve your child's position in
life even just a little and we're
talking about a lot right make your
child
oh man that's a winner
yeah
um there was about to remind me it was a
book called why raise
ugly kids
um and this is about I'm trying to think
this must be 50 to 100 years ago
you know this this really isn't new this
whole stuff it's
there's a huge volume of information
already out there um
yeah you know what I should write it but
I mean you know
yes I don't really it's a dyslexic I
don't relish the idea of writing books
to me but you and me I love reading them
right exactly well you know it's funny I
did not know that you were dyslexic
um I personally I'm not a believer that
dyslexia is actually a disorder and
actually I think you'll learn no no no
no no no no no no no no no it's it's a
different way of thinking well it's a
different way of thinking and uh I'm
fairly convinced that it is actually an
artifact of the expense of ink and paper
right the expense of ink and paper
caused us to choose a size of
effectively a font size that made good
use of these things and it was uh
conveyed information to a majority of
people but for you know basically my
sense is if you increase the font size
my dyslexia goes away you know it
doesn't mean that I don't have all of
the consequences of having been a
dyslexic my whole life those things
aren't going anywhere but from the point
of view of you know how good is my mind
at telling me what symbols are on the
page and in what order right that's a
question of oh it's too damn small
um yeah no no no no no no no I know I
kind of not even it's fascinating
because my sister's oldest is uh
so she then learned about it and she's
suddenly then going she's reading the
books and she's going that's my father
that's my brother my sister's going no
you're not dyslexic you're clearly
Asperger he says the reason people don't
notice that is because your chosen thing
you know all the people we have gifts
you know one of my gifts is interacting
with people
so I I love people I think you know
I just love engaging with people I love
conversations I love being out it's my
element and because of that she argues
people don't realize how weird I am
yeah well you know this is this is a
risky conversation to have Mike but my
sense is you know I I read very well as
I'm sure you do but I read very slowly
and it is yes exactly but I get it I say
we discussed the topic afterwards I
don't think didn't you see this this and
this and this okay it took me five times
longer to read it right that's it it's
expensive it's exhausting but one gets a
lot out of it when you put in the time
but it causes you to change your
threshold of what's actually worth
engaging in that way because it's so
costly right and one of the crazy things
about it is
especially in an era where a lot of
garbage flows through that channel
there's certainly no shortage of
amazing things that are written from
which you would benefit but the problem
is the signal to noise ratio ain't all
that great
and they're having a relationship with
the written word that is you know where
you don't treat it as just as candy
right where you treat it as like you
know uh well it's got to be worth my
time to sit down with that thing and
puzzle through it right that actually
has a benefit because it a causes you to
do more of your own thinking rather than
effectively
import
people's world view yeah yep good and
the bad in one Fell Swoop and I you know
I wonder how much this results in a guy
like you departing from their field
because
um you know yes there are some larger
things I'm sure in your field and
there's a lot of untrue things clearly
in your field and you know working from
first principles you're in a much better
position to say actually this this and
this makes sense but that and the other
thing don't and they have important
consequences
this again this is something like
fascinates me all the time and
I think that we've kind of got the
concept of science research back to
front
what people are doing is they're having
leaps of Reason intuitive leaps of
reason and then you do the science to
back it up
[Music]
yeah
well and it's you know
you know it's not the other but people
have this idea of the machine of it's
you know almost like science is like
Evolution you're just trying lots of
random things and seeing what you can
lift yourself up on you know
but it's not it's with the great science
is you know people like um Einstein
the the science he presented was to back
up that leap of imagination that he had
well
I I come at this from a slightly
different perspective I think what
you're saying is correct but I would
argue that it works like this
the thing that pays huge dividends is a
quality model
right if you have a quality model of the
universe that tells you it trains your
intuition right people have the sense
that intuition is like some uh mystical
process
it's not your intuition its quality is
based on how well trained your model is
if your model is high quality you can
have excellent intuitions about where to
look for something now the problem is
there's been this inversion I think it's
the thing that you're pointing at here
when you say it's it's backwards there's
been an inversion of priorities in the
academy and the reason actually has to
do with this very mundane feature of the
funding
to the extent that universities are
funded based on Grant overhead
they actually prefer expensive work
because expensive work gets big grants
those big grants build the buildings and
you know fuel the university which means
that there's been this coup
by the empiricists against the
theoreticians
and there's you you know the
theoretician like you know you need the
library you need you know sharp pencils
in modern times you need a computer with
a really good word processor but these
things don't really cost almost anything
right maybe the library does but
everybody needs that so it's there
anyway
so the point is we have gotten in this
mindset where we have become convinced
that you know theory is suspect and what
really you know data driven right
data-driven science itself yes and in
fact it's completely feeble it spends
most of its time searching for right
answers in places where a theoretician
can say you're not going to find them
there
simply out of the question that's an
empty spot you're looking at
and so
that thing has put those of us who
actually do work well in this
theoretical mode on the defensive when
in fact if civilization was
you know we have we have what what game
theorists would call a collective action
problem right where the system functions
better if it invests in something like
Theory but from the point of view of the
individuals each trying to do their job
whether they're University
administrators or scientists trying to
get grants the pressure is all in the
direction of if you do this you get paid
more and you have a better chance of you
know keeping your job and getting
promoted and if you do this other thing
like Theory well then your chances of
being shown the door go up your chances
of uh you know remaining stagnant in
your position go up and that thing is
driving us crazy because basically
Theory at least in my area
theory is treated as something that you
earn the right to do if your empirical
work is high quality then you get to
Muse about exactly then you get to write
the introduction
the
results and conclusion
in your own gist that's what it is you
know you you see these people you see
that I I gotta I got a Nobel Prize so
I'm got this fantastic piece of research
and now I'm gonna just gonna go crazy on
the um introduction particularly the
introduction because it's the
introduction where you pontificate and
kind of set up your conclusion so if a b
and c is possibly correct then that
would be validated by what I've already
found out down in conclusion right
exactly and it results in this even
worse catastrophe where because the
people who are doing this supposedly
high-powered empirical work to earn the
right to do the theory have at best a
very distant relationship with the
philosophy of science that makes the
whole thing work more often with
patience
say that again or often with patients
you know these guys you know they put
their mouth their fingers a patient you
know during undergraduate and a runaway
sense right
but that's that's degenerating you know
um you know I'm sure they put their
mouths in more patients fingers in more
patients mouths but there's this
disconnect between the people who are
actually treating patients and seeing
the outcome and seeing the results with
these people who are at the top end you
know processing the research and the
figurehead behind the research oh well
we certainly saw that with covid where
the doctors who were actually figuring
out what to do with these patients were
sidelined by some top-down uh you know
dictat that told them how to behave it's
an absurdity
um that the clinicians who had the
actual experience in that case
um uh were sidelined by basically like
um official pronouncements but
but the thing I was getting at was
science only works if the hypothesis
precedes
the test
yeah right if you came up with the
hypothesis after you collected a bunch
of data that did not get collected in
light of a hypothesis then you haven't
done science all you've done is actually
observation right and by pretending that
the hypothesis proceeded once you've
seen the pattern in the data you pretend
that the hypothesis that you came up
with after you saw the pattern really
existed before you say aha I've tested
this thing well you've violated the the
central principle that makes science
more powerful than other ways of
thinking and
almost impossible to detect it in the
literature because you don't know who
came up with what when we don't even
know how much of our literature is
polluted by the fact that even the
things that look theoretical aren't
because they're you know they're a
posterior
and what what I really like sometimes is
looking at things like astrophysics
where you've got this whole branch of
theoretical astrophysicists and
experimental astrophysicists and how
they have these
um it's interesting overlapping
ecosystems
and of course it doesn't really matter
to Joe blogs whether
um or to anyone in the industry whether
a star is a supernova at this point
under this you know this is because all
of um astrology is very abstract and I
guess until we start mining asteroids
it's going to be very abstract
that is not polluted well I'm sure
there's storms and teacups that you
wouldn't want to hear about however as a
general perspective these two ecosystems
work how can this little speck in the
middle of God damn nowhere have
understood just you know when we're
talking about they've found a new spiral
cluster of galaxies you think wow you
know and that's been done by this this
really good example of the experimental
and the philosophical
um ecosystems working fine because you
know who's making money who makes money
out of the fact that a supernova is
explodes at a certain certain weight of
star goes into a supernature doesn't no
it's it it's it's exactly right the
science is most intact there because
there's nothing riding on it like money
and you know frankly this is this is
what I discovered in the uh the episode
I alerted alluded to earlier when as a
graduate student I found this problem in
our drug safety testing which what I had
done you know I'm an animal behaviorist
right it's a little bit like supernovas
there's not a whole lot riding on you
know why the bat makes a tent you know
and where it does it right it's not a
monetary question but that's what I was
supposed to be working on and as when I
stumbled following my evolutionary
instinct when I stumbled into an area
that was involving medicine suddenly I
was now in a realm where there was
nothing but money at stake right money
and career and Nobel prizes and all of
that stuff and the point is oh my God
the science doesn't work in this area
because something has overridden it
science is this very powerful process
but like many powerful processes it's a
delicate process and I swear to you it
does not survive the encounter with the
market it can't right the market
overwhelms it and
um unfortunately
I kind of think that's where you are is
I mean look you've got a great
evolutionary understanding of
malocclusion and the problem is this
interfaces with dental appliances and an
industry of people yeah and none and
happening
yes I mean I I do I mean I think
I'm willing to I'm gonna definitely
definitely a lot of thinking whether
whether or not I win this case I'm
actually going to do less Dentistry yes
Orthodontics as orthotropics because I
want to free up other days because I
think that I could
help more people have a happier less
stressed life and make more money
doing other things like you know for
example we're going to release a mewing
app I mean clearly I'm I'm delay delay
delay delay delay delay but it will be
out at some point
and then you know if it should do
reasonably well given how popular
muing's been then I can earn some money
not every day with my hands
yep then hopefully I can start
I don't quite know I've got some ideas
but I just wanna you know I I kind of
naively
want to make the world a better place
you know yeah you use let's put it
differently you selfishly want to stop
us from maiming children right
but you know yeah the amount of good
here is immense potentially
yeah you know with really simple Health
Public Health messages you know
um sit up straight eat with a mouse chat
um elbows off the table um eat hard
Foods you know chew your food properly
I'm chew gum you know as I said with the
um five point prevention plan
it you know these are not complex things
and we need to try and engage with
parents of young children we need to set
up
um measurement strategies I want to do
research on these areas but have enough
funding to be able to do that have
enough
resources and not you know the problem
is at the moment when I you know phone
someone up
um try and contact someone the first
thing they'll do is they'll contact an
established Dental Authority that says
I'm a charlatan yeah but where'd you go
with that I mean how can I achieve
anything you know when you know it's
about building with people oh my you've
got to build part ships you've got to
build it oh really well they don't they
don't get back to me no one gets back to
me I I have had that exact experience in
the following situation okay I try to
alert people to this drug safety issue
right I had many journalists respond to
me and say what that's remarkable and
then they make a phone call and they
call somebody up somebody who they think
is well positioned this is true and then
what happens is they go radio silent
right it happened to me at least a dozen
times uh yeah yeah the damn device for
40 years right and
I don't know these people do not
understand how progress is actually made
that the idea was if somebody else was
in a position to say oh yeah Mike my
commute is making perfect sense right if
that person was in orthodontics then
there wouldn't be anything to do because
the point is you're actually trying to
call your Fields attention to this
massive error in its thinking of course
you're singular and that's how you know
if you're gonna say well look I'm just
I'm not gonna risk my career reporting
on anything that's singular well okay
then you've decided to take yourself out
of the running journalistically
of uh dealing with anything truly
important because you know all all great
ideas start as a minority of one
right so yeah you know basically the
journalistic system is structured not to
be able to understand what you're saying
your field is structured to be able to
resist it no matter how strong your case
is and you know I'm I'm gonna stop
harping on this but I do think at some
level you are on a collision course with
uh a book that will allow you to make
your case without your colleagues having
veto power
yeah yeah no no and I definitely need to
put a book out you know again you know
it's going to take me I think you know
okay so but but the catch up so I was in
the Press today
um I have I've read half of them because
you think I know they've taken the the
standard line from the general Dental
Council they've looked at the charge
sheet clearly I must be guilty of
something but and there you know it's me
that's now portrayed as the one that's
dangerous without science
hopefully they hang around till the end
of the case what's happened is the
They delayed the case we were late in
getting all our stuff in you know it's
just not easy getting an expert that
will defend me
as we said same system you know how do I
find experts to defend me you know
and and you know the situation I know
they even contacted you for your advice
um
now they've got the the our experts have
put forward the defense argument and I
think I I'm guessing
they were a little bit taken back
because I think we put together a really
good argument
and now they want more time
for the prosecution expert to read
through this stuff and look at it so
there's been a delay I hopefully it will
get going
um this year but it looks like it might
get kicked into the long grass again
more household you know I'm it's just
such a hassle to run a clinic when you
know all this press is going on anyway
either ways I'll probably cut back my
clinical hours because
what is showing me is that it's I need
time to think time not to be stressed
time to
to do something like write a book
you know but there's something about
working slogging your your your health
for a decade that's left me just drained
you know and there's there's court case
has left me drained
oh of course no it's absolutely
exhausting to be up against
your your colleagues uh trying to make a
point that frankly as you said at the
beginning of our conversation uh is as
effectively self-evident once you've put
in the hard work to get yourself there
right and so to have your colleagues
avoiding eye contact with what should
now be obvious to them is perfectly
exhausting right I mean it's effectively
I I've made a point of calling out
sophistry and this is sophistry right if
you're you know okay your colleagues
should have figured this out having not
figured it out they should be able to
understand it when it's placed in front
of them and if they can't that really
causing the question How Deeply they
could actually understand what they're
even doing
yeah it is a modern inflammatory to my
profession at the moment but
yeah well you know like I mean I I guess
I'm in the fortunate position of not
having to be kind to these people
um but but damn it you know I I still I
still have this vision of trying to
encourage my profession down the right
way you know engaging with proper debate
you know
you're gonna have to defeat them
that's that's I hope I hope that I get
as much press interest even when I win
the case
yeah
um I
I yeah you're gonna disappoint me again
I can tell I'm I'm look I am hoping that
this happens and that you are the
unusual Cape of the person who manages
to stare down their discipline and your
discipline realizes how much trouble
it's in if it actually continues to go
after you I really really hope that you
you succeed in that but um I do I have
had a lot of encounters with power and
uh
power is very powerful
hmm
yeah yeah well again you know it would
be interesting it'd be interesting to
see how this goes because I'm hoping
that because this is this
all to assist you know we're we're out
in
um Orthodontics is this strange
profession that's fairly dislocated from
the rest of modern medicine so I'm
hoping that it's
it I can make Headway in this profession
and I can
use that Headway to then come swing left
and help people like yourself or younger
versions of yourself
yeah where you were when you first came
to those conclusions
yeah I mean I would recommend
um that you check out a podcast uh I did
with Steve Patterson
um Steve Patterson is an unknown guy but
he's effectively a
self-made historian and philosopher of
science
uh who he and I
converged from very different places on
the idea that we are living in something
like a dark age
and that that's not an exaggeration
um that something has gone off the rails
with respect to this process of thinking
scientifically
that uh got us this far and in any case
the upshot is I think
the system is ejecting people
who remember how to do this work
and that is having two consequences it's
Wrecking
field after field they just get stuck
and they don't know what to do the
consequences can be anything from Just
sidelining For example physics for
decade after decade to doing active harm
as you're seeing in your field as I
believe I saw with respect to drug
safety
um but the other consequence on the
positive side
it's forcing out the people who remember
how to do the work and those people are
finding each other that the internet has
actually allowed that to happen yes it
is you know but when I I sit through I
your work when I hear I mean
there's quite a number of people who I
watch on the internet and I'm I'm just
just shocked how much I agree with them
how they're thinking along the same
lines as me and how they've suffered
from similar levels of persecution right
yeah you know
and it just seems like
yeah there must be there's clearly going
to be convergence here yeah it's
converted well
the way I see it is
um
Goliath is very powerful
um and he's also kind of a [ __ ] and
what he's doing is he is taking all of
the best players
and he is forcing them together and in
the end he's not going to know what hit
him
yeah
you know I I've been interesting article
I read in the um Economist uh recently I
love The Economist I I bet my my bets
are really I need to get out of science
so I read the economics so my I'm a I
read The Economist and they have a nice
science section and they had an article
pointing out that Einstein probably
wouldn't get published today no it
certainly wouldn't get published today
and if he threw that theory in it would
be lost somewhere and I sometimes wonder
that the next Einstein is probably out
there right now
you know he went from a job in the
patent office to working in um you know
in McDonald's and he's still there in
McDonald's because you know no one
published that paper he didn't get
picked up and he's gonna die some point
you know because you know we forget
everyone thoughts Einstein's such a
genius the man in back in the
um pre-war between War periods he had a
University degree and he couldn't get a
job teaching maths at a high school I
mean how you know you must be literally
in that the end pile of nowhere not even
can consider that Blake
now and this is happening and I can tell
you from my own field that the people
who did the most important work in the
mid 20th century would not be allowed to
work in that manner anymore it was too
theoretical right and so the point is
you know where's your where's your giant
Grant
um that's true and it is also true uh
both my advisor and Heather's advisor
took us aside late in our graduate
careers and said you know I this is the
advisor speaking don't think I could do
what I ended up doing if I had to do it
now
right that they told us this and they
said the fields just don't function
um and you know
they hadn't talked to each other this
was two people who independently came to
that conclusion
um so anyway I think you know we are in
some place where this
basically
there's some analogy between generation
after generation of humans developing
malocclusion because something
fundamental is wrong with the way
they're being raised and something
fundamental having gone wrong in the way
we train scientists that has now caused
that system to have the equivalent of
malocclusion but okay wait a minute I'm
just just thinking because you you you
you you know I'm gonna add some light
here because I think you've been quite
okay okay pretty dark so we've got a
thing here is now this I'm going to say
two things that one of them I guess is a
little bit dark as well
okay I'll say that one first I guess so
when I qualified as a dentist I did my
undergraduate in the Royal London
Hospital East End of London it was a
great hospital at the time because it
was a very poor area so you have a line
of patience every morning like this
outside the hospital no better hospital
to train and work on because you've got
the experience
at the time sleep apnea wasn't in the
syllabus
yeah I know it wasn't because you had
you know left-sided congestive failure
you sit by guys up in bed and you call
that parasok mall uh nocturnal sleep
apnea you know it's got the word sleep
apnea in it so I remembered learning the
word sleep apnea and I remember that was
uni one place I learned that you know
and you're in you're cramming for your
exams
so I know that sleep apnea was not
definitive it was not in the syllabus in
dentistry in when I qualified in 93. now
as I said when I talked to Vic Veer he
he's saying it's killing 20 of the
adults
um a decade early in the west nice
um countries so that means that's a one
in five it's gone from nowhere to
shortening Your Life by One in five by a
decade that's a crazy increase so that
increase I think what we're hitting a
bit of a brick wall so I don't think
we're going to be a craniofacial
dystrophy this thing I think I've
defined
is is up that curve and I think fairly
soon we cannot not observe it we can't
say it's not happening because it's just
gonna be crazy it would be so
objectively obvious that I don't think
they know any way not to say hates I
mean career serious is going on here the
other thing is you know when I look at
mewing and how well it's done and when I
so I gave a lecture and I went I elected
to the ancestral Health symposium
in I'm UCLA in
um the beginning of August
and it's like I love you know wow I wish
we had campuses like that in the UK you
know I mean just
wow you know just so lovely you know the
weather's so nice you're just on the
edge of the daily bits there
round from Beverly Hills and
we I thought I'd do a poll so I was
stopping the students
and maybe I had a good day I stopped 10
students and six of them really knew
what mewing was hmm
now that's clearly a completely biased
sample but when you've got such a large
body of young people and I said you know
on Tick Tock as one metric the muing
hashtag has been seen 1.7 billion times
then we're putting this information out
onto fertile ground and these people
these kids these the Next Generation
coming up are seeing this as a given
fact
so they're going to start having their
children at some point and they're going
to be thinking very differently so I
think that by chance wow what a what an
amazing luck piece of luck I had that
mewing is something to do with faces
kids are interested in doing it and it's
it's out there now and you can't stop
that look
there's a chance we can bring the ship
around oh you know look uh I do
I don't think of it as dark I think of
it as realism but yeah what you're
saying is absolutely correct I do think
if you're willing to look at a
multi-generation time scale
that you have gone around your field and
they're not in a position to shut you
down because mewing is a feature of the
culture at this point it doesn't go
through the orthodontists and so there's
no pivotal control point right but I
would say that is Nature's way of
telling you the way to accelerate that
process is to lean into it and win early
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's my thing
you know okay I've worked for decade you
know I'm struggling to make money here I
I'm just you know I'm trying to make my
license you know great you know that's a
great thanks for trying so hard and yet
knewing that I've done next to nothing
to encourage is just blowing up so
clearly where do I go yeah clearly where
do you go that's the thing you got to
pay attention but I also think you know
and I I hope that you end up
um you know financially successful as a
result of this but that's going to
require a little bit of
um you looking at this not so much as
how do I solve the problem that you know
it takes too much time to do what I do
in the clinic
how do you scale up so that as with
mewing
people take this on themselves they're
you know they start going into their
uh their orthodontists or you know maybe
they go to their dentist and they say
you know what should I be feeding my
child so that this yeah yeah yeah we
need
but a lot of this is going to be getting
that Spotlight of modern medical
research you know even if the the
majority doesn't you know if I can make
enough money off the back of mirroring
if I can get some good grants you know
someone out there you know some
anthropologist
you've got you know if you're in your
60s you know you've got a 20 chance of
dying a decade earlier from sleep apnea
is as consequences and I believe I've
got the answers right to that extra
decade you know start throwing me you
know lump million lump sums right
because that's what it takes to move the
narrative forwards and I would know what
to do with that yeah no two generations
of my family we have demonstrated that
we have the we we've we've gained your
trust already
yep
yep and and you know
let's put it this way if you had a
nonsense story about why this was true
but you had a good clinical practice a
good approach that would be positive
enough the fact that you've got both
sides of this thing nailed right you
know how to deal with the issue you know
how to prevent the issue and a very good
handle on why this has happened right
you know but it's going to come I think
I think I I could see some sort of
random card coming out you know I could
see the Sultan of Oman phone me out and
go look I I can I can see what you want
I can see what you're doing and for the
for the investment of my country I want
my eldest son to look good I want him to
having a strapping jawline I want him to
look like a leader because I think that
then we can extend the way our my
government goes for another generation
that's a plausible scenario yep and he
says I don't care how much it costs Mike
literally you get the best people you
know we're going to give them a offer
they couldn't refuse to come and live in
wherever I am and we're going to make
certain my my son and you know all of
the other aristocracy Sons you know and
I'm gonna go as well as long as I can
make them kick ass
I'll take you on
yep
um I see that as uh that will be
unfortunate if that's the way it has to
go I think it's just it's shame but
hopefully they're not gonna be less
Hands-On and I can organize a team to do
it and then we can replicate that team
and then you know reverse engineer that
backwards into the UK and other
countries that need it yep what I'd
rather happen rather than this becoming
a tool of the aristocracy is I would
like some publisher to realize just how
much money they could make providing you
the mechanism to reach the full audience
oh yeah it's really tough knowing what
the next step is it's you know I've
tried to build a business on the back of
me making people better and it's it
works you know you give me unlimited
resources I think I could change the
facial form of almost any child
to be you know great I could make almost
any child have
architectural structure that looked good
now that's quite a big statement to make
and I'd need them from a reasonably
young to be able to do that no I think
you know it's clear that what you need
is for people to understand that this
problem starts very very early and for
them not to cause it yeah yeah
yeah well in my looking for my defense I
was digging up lots of old texts written
back in the
um 1890s 1810 1910 1920s and you you
talk listen to these guys and they're
saying you know um clearly it's a little
bit
um you know there's a lot of racism
within the language they're using
because they're talking about the
um uh black Farm boys and how they're
growing into being fantastic facial form
because they eat sugar cane and they're
describing their mechanism of how they
think but I'm thinking you're spot on
you know underneath this you know take
the veneer of clear clear Prejudice
language
these guys are clearly saying you know
these guys are chewing tough sugarcane
at a very young age almost before
they've got teeth yep right and that's
what's really causing the development in
the dental arches right so yeah
yeah that's actually that's that's a
still a piece of information that
circulates
um Heather and I have done a lot of uh
work in the neotropics where sugar cane
is grown and this is a piece of
information that we hear somewhat
regularly is that you would think that
you know the teeth in and around the
sugar fields
would be all messed up and it's actually
quite the opposite both uh
um because of the abrasive nature of the
sugar cane when it's not when the sugar
isn't divorced from the cane it actually
uh isn't the hazard to teeth that people
would imagine yeah no I think it's the
concentration the processing that I
think is half the problem right well you
know as with lots of things right coca
leaves are uh utilized in the Andes by
people who are working at a high
altitudes the concentration of the stuff
into cocaine that makes it dangerous
yeah and the way the tobacco was used by
the Native American Indians as as a a
healing herb yep exactly and you know uh
food calories preserved in beer is a you
know long-standing mechanism for getting
people through uh the winter months you
know
there's lots of this stuff where the
natural version of something is
um safe and useful and the uh
concentrated modern version is is lethal
or taking it to excess right yeah thank
you it simply wouldn't have been
possible in a society where you didn't I
wouldn't have access to excess right and
in fact you can tell a very similar
story with respect to
um marijuana which was a comparatively
safe much better than alcohol in fact
intoxicant and the way that the law
prosecuted people on the basis of the
weight of marijuana that they were
caught with caused it to be in absurdly
concentrated and it is that absurd
concentration which basically transforms
it into a different drug
hmm
no no no I mean
I think well I mean you know what they
say about common sense
the problem with common sense is it's
not very common yes yeah nevertheless so
you know I mean just you need to see
behind sight again you know I think that
again when we started I said my
definition of knowing someone is knowing
them for a long period of time because
that gives you multiple interactions
over a significant period which is how
you get to know someone
um I think truth comes out in time you
know my father has this interesting
phase that you know he thinks humans can
be amazingly stupid but they normally
get there in the end
yeah they don't really get to the right
answer in the end yeah normally getting
the right answer we're gonna have to
call a day because um my wife's gonna be
um yep wondering where I am uh let's do
it Mike it's been a real pleasure uh I
wish you all the luck in the world with
your hearing thank you very much
um hang in there and irrespective of
what happens with your hearing know that
a lot of us have uh recognized that what
you're saying
is extremely sensible and uh anyway
um whether you're inside or outside of
the system or both we're rooting for you
cool cool and I think the one thing
Bradley bike and a shout out on your
channel is you know to help people share
this information you know I it's
fantastic to come on your program back
how you know what we've been on before
with anyone else out there who thinks
they would like to interview me on the
subject I think I'd love the air time to
spread this and propagate this message
because I think it's so important you
know when we're talking about preventing
crooked teeth as well as these other
things we think like sleep apnea are
symptoms of incorrect facial growth it's
important and it's really simple things
we could be doing yeah I couldn't be
more important really
um yeah so anyway I I hope that many
offers of interviews come your way soon
how how much longer do you expect your
hearing to take place so it's delayed
now we're going to meet up next Monday
so a month day
six days time
we
they will decide at that point whether
it's going to go forward the Monday
afterwards so I booked off through I
booked off four weeks three weeks we had
booked in at the general Denver Council
um Akili is not going to go ahead in the
first two weeks
um that third week we're going to find
out if it's going to go ahead on that
third week in a week's time
and we are having this conversation on
November 15th November 15th Tuesday
November the 15th so
um if it doesn't go ahead in that third
week then it could be kicked into the
long grass and we could it could be up
to a year Beyond if it's not kicked into
the long grass if we have that
um restart it whether we're going to
have to finish it relatively quickly
yeah so that's my hope that we can get
this going relatively quickly because
it's just you know I sit here in limbo
you know about how do I employ staff and
I've just had a member that's gone and
how can I imply nobody like oh you do
you want a job with me yeah I might be
struck off
you know any patients coming one the
three-year treatment with me oh I might
be struck off right uh yeah no I see the
predicament they're uh you know
yeah and then you know and then even if
I win this what's my insurance going to
look like right
you know and that's how a lot of people
a lot of great ideas on Dentistry have
been stopped because people couldn't get
insurance
wow I did not know that you know so you
throw enough crap at people you just
overwhelm them you know this is you know
um big oil companies have been doing
this to small people for a generation
just throw lowercases at them oh yeah
okay with Brett little with that thank
you very much indeed thank you for the
honor to speak to you sir nice to chat
through to a like-minded person to the
fat of life to the fair of life is a
good way of putting it thanks so much
Mike I really appreciate it and I uh got
my fingers crossed for you
[Music]